Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz una entrevista
especial desde la Feria Internacional
del Libro de Bogotá en este nuestro
Stand de France 24 hasta donde ha venido
Rafael dumet a visitarnos para conversar
es dramaturgo escritor peruano y muchas
gracias por estar aquí Rafael muchas
gracias a ustedes por el interés de
conversar conmigo
reditaste el año pasado la primer su
primera novela en alfaguara el espía del
inca narra El secuestro y los intentos
de liberar atahualpa el último soberano
inca a casi 500 años de su muerte qué
nos dice del presente este hecho
histórico es muy interesante
me resulta difícil en general
escribir manuales instrucciones para los
demás sobre Cómo leer
las cosas que ocurren y sobre todo mi
libro pero me parece muy sintomático lo
que ocurrió por ejemplo en México cuando
el presidente López Obrador por ejemplo
conversó con él con el trato de
establecer una conversación con el rey
de España para ver cómo conmemoraban
juntos estos quinientos años o
celebraban los denostaban había que
tener algún tipo de acuerdo y sin
embargo en el momento en el cual
este presidente mexicano de manera muy
populista además y con un provecho
político en la búsqueda de un provecho
político obvio la reacción de los
españoles fue muy divertida muy
histérica en el sentido de que como se
atrevían justamente a a a a a a a tratar
de culparlos de alguna manera estas
cosas que había ocurrido hace tanto
tiempo no y que los problemas actuales
de los mexicanos sería ya un problema
que correspondían a los mexicanos
hubo algunas plumas bastante prominentes
que inclusive se desgarraron las
vestiduras por este asunto y me a mí me
pareció muy sintomático Por una parte
este esta utilización política por parte
del presidente mexicano
muy sintomática de los tiempos y también
por otra parte la reacción histérica de
los españoles ante esta demanda que me
pareció bastante lógica cómo vamos a
hacerle cómo vamos a conmemorar cómo
vamos a recordar estos eventos yo
sospecho que a nosotros nos va a tocar a
los peruanos quiero decir tener que
lidiar con algo análogo similar cuando
llegue el año 2032 en que se van a
cumplir 500 años de bueno la captura y
muerte de atahualpa no entonces este yo
no sabía cómo cómo
Cómo leer no sabía Cómo leer lo que
estaba ocurriendo Más allá de que acabo
de mencionarle no y centrándonos más en
el terreno político peruano con esa
destitución de Pedro Castillo en
diciembre y todas las protestas
posteriores hay también en los pueblos
indígenas peruanos un sentimiento de un
nuevo secuestro de atahualpa yo creo que
hay que diferenciar muy claramente las
proyecciones que pueden tener la gente
con respecto a un gobernante que no ha
defendido los intereses de las mayorías
hay que decirlo hay que señalar
claramente que en el gobierno del señor
Castillo se aprobaron por se aprobó por
ejemplo se sancionó por ejemplo la
construcción de un aeropuerto en el
valle sagrado de los incas Entonces por
supuesto ha primado el interés económico
no ha habido ningún tipo de discusión e
inclusive ha sido considerada como una
reivindicación yo no sé local de tipo
comercial
yo no no considero ni necesariamente que
el hecho de que un gobernante tenga tipo
de discurso o Aparentemente sirva para
que la gente se proyecte en él eso
significa necesariamente nada con
respecto a la importancia que puede
tener para mí es simplemente ha sido un
señor muy interesante en la medida en
que tenía un humilde un origen muy
humilde y que en ese sentido
representaba la esperanza comprensible
de mucha gente de que fuera algo
diferente Pero ha terminado siendo un
delincuente de poca monta y que ha sido
justamente expectorado del poder no
Entonces en ese sentido creo que Eh
bueno no no definitivamente estoy en
desacuerdo con ese diagnóstico que usted
ha mencionado y Pero puede ser que se
haya convertido como en un símbolo esas
protestas trascendían tal vez su figura
y es esa constante sentimiento de
desprecio desde y tiene usted razón en
ese sentido sí creo que por ejemplo es
sintomático que es muy interesante por
ejemplo antes de pensar a la conquista
estoy pensando en una rebelión
anticolonial que ocurrió en 1780 por un
el líder indígena que se llamaba túpac
Amaru segundo y es interesante que los
mismos sectores las exactamente
literalmente las mismas regiones
cusco puno el altiplano cajamarca en
realidad no tanto llegamos los en el sur
del Perú cajamarca creo que por el
contrario ha realizado movilizaciones
pero no ha sido violentas pero la
movilizaciones violentas pero violentas
en el sentido de bueno de que han
tratado de de de de de de levantarse
frente a esta a este a este a esta a
este golpe de estado ha sido por una
cuestión de que ellos han ellos ellos
básicamente han han tratado de expresar
su protesta por el hecho de que okay
este señor puede ser un mal gobernante
puede ser corrupto pero nosotros lo
elegimos entonces Este creo que es
interesante que para terminar mi
razonamiento de que los mismos las
mismas regiones literalmente los hasta
los mismos pueblos son exactamente los
mismos que se rebelaron en la rebelión
segundo y que fue la rebelión colonial
más importante de toda la colonia en la
cual murieron 100.000 muertos entonces
tiene usted razón hay una coincidencia y
tiene usted razón hay algo que no ha
sido corregido en todo ese tiempo no
usted estuvo 10 años escribiendo la
novela y he leído que incluso Desde niño
le fascinaba la figura de atahualpa
quién era atahualpa me fascinaba
no en el sentido de que Ajá atahualpa no
me fascinaba en el sentido de la
ambigüedad del personaje Por una parte
la encarnado por supuesto No En la
imagen de inca gobernante y soberano que
era la persona que nos gobernó a
nosotros pero por otra parte ha
encarnado la imagen de este perdedor
supremo no
ante el cual tenemos una imagen un poco
ambigua un poco extraña y no solamente
la tengo Yo creo que los digamos los
territorios actualmente ocupados por el
Perú Ecuador
chile e incluso Argentina por alguna
razón hay doscientas
doscientas ceremonias anuales que de
alguna manera recuerdan el asesinato de
hinchas atahualpa tengo la impresión de
que es un evento no resuelto en el
inconsciente colectivo que hay algo
histérico colectivamente que hace que
nosotros estemos obsesionados de una y
otra de una u otra manera con esta
muerte este asesinato que nos sigue
conmoviendo
remeciendo 500 años después
entonces Este creo que eso es lo que
podría yo he tratado creo Creo que en
ese en esa medida he sido simplemente
una persona que ha sido posiblemente
sensible a esta a esta a esta histeria a
este conflicto no resuelto y he tratado
de alguna manera de de de de de de
resolverlo es lo que estoy diciendo es
por supuestamente es el producto en una
reflexión muy posterior después de haber
escrito la novela No ese espía También
conocido como escollos Arango debía
ayudar a liberar atahualpa pero también
entre sus misiones estaba resolver si
los españoles eran dioses o no Cuándo
acaba esa pregunta para para los incas
para bastante rápido
en realidad
dioses no es la palabra correcta en la
que correspondería esto puesto que creo
que hay que utilizar el término de huaca
huaca es un ser de características
sobrenaturales No necesariamente divinas
pero que uno trata de básicamente lo que
atahualpa y también las personas que que
recibían los españoles trataban de mirar
era estos señores tienen poderes pero
vamos a ver qué poder realmente tienen a
ver o que tienen estas estas digamos
estas especies de cilindros que parecen
ser batanas y pero de la que evite que
que que botan fuego y parece que ese
fuego mata a la gente tienen estas
llamas gigantes que bueno Aparentemente
corren muy rápido tienen mucha fuerza y
y esto Esto es esto corresponde a la
categoría de huaca es decir un ser
sobrenatural que se manifiesta y y Pero
esto digamos los también morir los veían
también ser heridos los veían también
enfermarse ser afectados por la altura
entonces la imagen Era ambigua y y no
era tan tan tan absoluta de que Ah no
son divinos hay que adorarlos no no era
así de hecho la actitud fundamental por
parte del inca atahualpa ante ellos fue
de cómo cómo hago para aprovechar
políticamente a estos a estos señores
que han venido de no sé de dónde
Aparentemente
vienen de las mismos lugares de los que
han venido los seres legendarios
anteriores pero cómo cómo qué poderes
tiene Cómo los puedo utilizar hay que
comprender atahualpa puesto que estaba
en una posición prepolítica muy precaria
él acababa de ganar la guerra civil
contra su hermano y necesitaba de
cualquier apoyo que pudiera conseguir es
en esa medida que él vio a los españoles
como posibles aliados y trató de
conseguirselos como como como aliados
Pero bueno ya sabemos Qué pasó No que
como ocurrieron las cosas y cuál fue el
desenlace vamos con Una última pregunta
Rafael el imperio inca iba desde
Colombia prácticamente hasta chile
Argentina como comentabas sin embargo no
había entre todos los pueblos indígenas
una gran conciencia de ese imperio las
diferentes etnias las veían Incluso como
opresores es verdad Pero hay que
comprender una vez más creo que no hay
que ser anacrónico y no hay que por
ejemplo proyectar nociones de raza que
no existía nociones de nación que no
existían el el habitante común y
corriente inclusive el líder étnico
común y corriente ni siquiera tenía una
idea con posiblemente de la existencia
del del tahuantinsuyo Es decir de este
de este gran estado de de cuatro partes
no ellos básicamente miraban lo que
aquello que que le él tenía el líder
étnico común y corriente tenía una serie
de contratos con este este este
conquistador este este este victorioso
esta entidad victoriosa mayor que por
ejemplo posiblemente le ayudaba para
conseguir recursos hidráulicos le por
ejemplo garantizaba que estuviera
protegido en guerras con sus vecinos
pero pero Digamos como contrapartida le
exigía o que tú tienes que cada vez que
yo tengo una guerra Tienes que mandarme
por ejemplo hombres en edad productiva
para que sirvan en mi jefe ejércitos
tienes que además este garantizar que
Ustedes deben producir durante tres
meses
maíz y en general productos para llenar
los depósitos del inca digamos que era
una especie de contrato muy puntual
Entonces tuve Qué pasó que
el acababa de haber 11 años de guerra de
conquista por parte del inca anterior el
inca buena capa y había habido una
guerra civil de cuatro o cinco años
ponerse en el lugar de estos líderes
técnicos que estaban completamente
hartos de que los impuestos hay que
estoy utilizando esta palabra de manera
bastante lata estuvieron subiendo
constantemente en términos de tiempo de
servicio en términos de productos que
había que servir en términos de todo
entonces era completamente comprensible
que ellos vieran a estos visitantes
extranjeros como posibles salvadores
bueno el chasco se dieron cuenta
bastante rápido unos años después de que
había sido un gran chasco pero pero
digamos esa era una una perspectiva
completamente comprensible no muchas
gracias Rafael por haber estado acá en
nuestro Stand de France 24 en la filbo
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes de nuevo
por el interés Pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en France 24 y
France 24.com